our home is burning
rapid climate change is destabilizing
our world it seems our emissions will
not fall quickly enough to avoid runaway
warming and we may soon hit tipping
points that will lead to the collapse of
ecosystems and our civilization
while scientists activists and much of
the younger generation urge action it
appears most politicians are not
committed to doing anything meaningful
while the fossil fuel industry still
works actively against change
it seems humanity can't overcome its
greed and obsession with short-term
profit and personal gain to save itself
and so for many the future looks grim
and hopeless
young people feel particularly anxious
and depressed instead of looking ahead
to a lifetime of opportunity they wonder
if they will even have a future or if
they should bring kids into this world
it's an age of doom and hopelessness and
giving up seems the only sensible thing
to do
but
that's not true
you are not doomed humanity is not
doomed
[Music]
despite the seriousness of the situation
for years positive trends have
accumulated and there is finally some
good news and a clear path towards our
collective climate goals welcome to our
ted talk please watch this video to the
end check out our detailed sources
afterwards to learn more
okay let's start with the scariest
things
cancelling the apocalypse
some of the most widely shared stories
about climate change are that it is an
existential threat the end of human
civilization and maybe even our own
extinction event
and that it's basically unavoidable now
but what does science actually say
as of 2022 the global average
temperature has risen 1.2 degrees
celsius compared to pre-industrial times
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees was the
most ambitious goal of the paris
agreement but we are not likely to meet
it
already with the warming we have today
hot places will get hotter wet places
wetter and the risk and strength of
extreme weather events increase
significantly
warming beyond two degrees makes all of
these extremes more extreme extreme
weather events more common with more
ecosystems under major pressure
some will not survive
at three degrees significant parts of
earth especially in developing countries
might become unable to feed their
populations
heat waves will become a major global
issue
large-scale natural systems will break
down the scale and frequency of
hurricanes fires and droughts will
further increase and cause trillions in
damage
poor regions and subsistence farmers
will be hit the hardest
hundreds of millions of people will need
to leave their homes
in the four to eight degree range the
apocalypse begins the hot house earth
where things change so quickly that it
may become unable to support our large
human population and billions may perish
leaving the rest on a hostile alien
planet
a decade ago for lack of action and
perspective many scientists assumed a
four plus degree world was our future
and a lot of public communication
focused on exactly this future path
luckily it's much less likely that this
version of the apocalypse will come to
pass
if current climate policies stagnate
we're likely to end up with warming of
around three degrees celsius by 2100
which is scary and tragic and far from
acceptable
but this is actually good news
how
in the last decade we've seen enough
progress that most scientists now think
that we have likely avoided apocalyptic
climate change
although substantial risk still remains
we can pretty confidently say that
humanity isn't going anywhere
civilization might have to change
but it will endure
which begs the question
what has changed over the last 10 years
and is this really good news
the invisible shift
you probably know this story the last
decade has been an immense failure for
climate policies around the world
instead of passing comprehensive binding
bills that would meaningfully reduce
emissions we mostly did nothing a lost
decade with one negative record after
another and this story is true and it's
one reason why so many people are giving
up but it is not the whole picture
despite the lack of climate policies and
ongoing lobbying and misinformation
campaigns from the fossil fuel
industries there was a lot of progress
let's go back 20 years to see why today
is so different
between 2000 and 2010 greenhouse gas
emissions had grown by 24 percent three
times as much as the increase in the
previous decade
subsidies for fossil fuels aimed at
promoting economic growth caused a
colossal increase in their consumption
for developing countries like china and
india coral was the cheapest fuel for
growth while rich countries showed
little interest in changing their ways
in 2010 many people expected these
trends to continue instead of decreasing
fossil fuel use its consumption would
rise
the next decade turned out to be very
different though
first of all coal burning in developing
countries like india has slowed down or
leveled off like in china and it's
plummeted in rich countries like the uk
and us
since 2015 three quarters of planned
coal plants have been cancelled and 44
countries have committed to stop
building them
ten years ago that would have seemed
like wishful thinking but today we can
say with confidence coal is dying it's
just not competitive anymore because
technologies we thought would remain
expensive matured rapidly instead
renewable electricity has shown
explosive progress
in a mere decade wind energy got three
times cheaper
solar electricity is now 10 times
cheaper
cheaper than coal or any other fossil
fuel burning power plant despite the
massive subsidies and global
infrastructure propping up fossil fuels
25 times more solar and nearly five
times more wind electricity is produced
today compared with 10 years ago which
is of course not nearly enough
one of the biggest obstacles is the
variability of their power output
renewables need a lot of energy storage
to be a reliable power source like
expensive batteries
amazingly battery prices have decreased
by 97 in the past 30 years 60 in the
last decade alone which will serve all
kinds of green technology like electric
cars
you might say well that's great but
didn't kotskazak's last climate video
say that while wind and solar are nice
we need nothing less than a fundamental
transition of our global industrial
system
yes but luckily the shift goes beyond
just the energy sector throughout the
economy people are working on improving
current technology to lower emissions
we're rapidly replacing old incandescent
light bulbs with leds that are 10 times
more efficient
in 2020 about seven out of ten new cars
in norway were electric or hybrid in
2021 it was already eight out of ten
and the list goes on from electric
heating and better insulation to ships
traveling at half speed to save fuel
wherever you look you find scientists
engineers and entrepreneurs trying to
solve some aspect of climate change
enormous amounts of human ingenuity are
being brought to bear on this problem
with more and more people deciding to
prioritize preventing rapid climate
change
solutions for low carbon production of
cement electronics and steel and
innovations like artificial meat and
carbon capture are in the works
the more of these technologies we deploy
the cheaper new and better technology
gets
the cheaper they get the more people use
them and so on we can see the impact
already the domestic co2 output of rich
countries is falling without a major
recession
since the year 2000 the eu as a whole
shows a 21 decrease at least 28
the uk 35
denmark 43
but the best news may be that emissions
are no longer necessarily coupled with
economic growth
in the past this was an inconvenient
truth to get richer you had to emit more
which led to fierce arguments between
developing and developed countries about
the fairness of reducing emissions while
their populations were still poor but in
the last decade we've seen that it is
possible to increase prosperity without
increasing emissions emissions in the
czech republic dropped 13 percent while
their gdp grew by 27
france reduced their co2 emissions by 14
while increasing gdp by 15 percent
romania saw an 8 decrease and 35 percent
growth
and even the largest economy on earth
the usa decreased emissions by 4
while growing their gdp by 26
some of you may call this a numbers
trick
that rich countries are just exporting
emissions to poorer nations by moving
the dirty parts of their economies like
manufacturing but even when we account
for all of our imported goods the
numbers still look positive
it's no longer a matter of having to
choose between prosperity and the
climate as it seemed to be a decade ago
developing countries will profit from
that because as rich countries pay for
the expensive development of green
technologies they can adopt them more
cheaply they can skip most of the higher
mission phase that today's rich
countries went through
we are at the point where not
decarbonizing is a bad business decision
and we haven't even really talked about
solutions like carbon capture
in 2000 it didn't really exist
in 2022 that technology does exist and
costs around 600 to remove one tonne of
co2 from the atmosphere
as investment pours in and the
technology matures and begins to scale
it's likely that these costs will
plummet over the next few decades
so everything's fine then
well let's not get carried away all of
these processes are great but not nearly
fast enough we're still doing way too
little and technology will not magically
solve everything we need to use fewer
resources and use them longer design
consumer goods that are repairable and
durable and decrease our energy
requirements
we need much better infrastructure
agriculture and cities it will still be
hard work especially to get the right
policies passed and enacted but for the
first time ever there are a few trend
lines pointing solidly in the right
direction and now imagine if all of this
was achieved without proper financial
and political support and despite fossil
fuel lobbying just think what humanity
can do when climate change finally gets
the political attention and funding it
needs so is it okay to feel hopeful
again the situation is still dire and
serious so what's the point of focusing
on this side of the story
the trap of hopelessness
climate change can feel overwhelming and
make your future seem bleak
the sadness and hopelessness that many
people feel is real and very destructive
because it causes apathy apathy that is
only serving the fossil fuel industry
that is still delaying change however it
can in a sense they have weaponized
hopelessness
we are now in phase four in the public
debate about rapid climate change action
phase one was climate change is not real
phase two was climate change is real but
not caused by humans phase three was
climate change may be caused by humans
but it's not that bad
phase four is climate change is no
longer avoidable
we are doomed and it doesn't matter what
we do
if we want the world to change we first
need to believe that change is possible
and we have an abundance of evidence
that it is
changes to our industrial system are
gaining momentum technology gets better
and cheaper climate change has become a
key issue in most free elections
as more and more younger people move
into influential positions they
prioritize climate change and work on
new solutions
in 2022 most governments not only
acknowledge it but set their own net
zero goals in democratic and autocratic
countries
the results of years of fighting a steep
uphill battle are now clearly visible
the pressure needs to keep increasing to
make sure that the promises made today
are actually kept
climate dumerism is the equivalent of
giving up even though you can still
prevent not just the worst case but also
mitigate most of the bad things make
changes in time to adapt better and
prevent the poorest from suffering
that is why hopelessness and apathy are
so dangerous
if the last in many ways wasted decade
has shown anything then it's that
progress is being made and the dire
scenarios are just predictions not our
sealed fate as of 2022 based on current
global policies we will end up in a
three degrees world
now it's our job to yet again prove the
predictions wrong despite how serious
and urgent things are to turn that three
degrees into a two degrees and then see
where we can go from there for that we
need hope
and we hope we gave you that today at
least a little that you feel that things
are serious but also that you have a
future that you can have kids without
dooming them or the world
that taking action today is worth it
and that despite powerful industries
doing everything to delay it society is
changing
if you need a more concrete roadmap of
what you can do personally we're working
on a follow-up video to talk about that
in greater detail
dumarism inactivity and weaponized
hopelessness are the only trump cards
left for the powers that don't want
change
don't let them win
we're still excited about the future
and we think one of the best things you
can do to keep your optimism and
curiosity up is to learn new things
if you don't know where to start our
friends from brilliant.org have got you
covered brilliant makes maths and
science accessible and fun with a
hands-on approach
more than 60 interactive courses like
the joy of problem solving or scientific
thinking give you the tools to crack
problems in maths science and computer
science that are all designed to get
your intuition going and give you plenty
of aha experiences
lessons will surprise you with
storytelling code writing tasks and
interactive challenges basically using
whatever keeps you interested and
entertained
all the content is interactive instead
of just reading and listening to
explanations you drag and drop
manipulate shapes and diagrams make
selections and answer questions
this way you learn something almost
without you noticing it
and tiny step by step you'll build up
your long-term understanding of science
and get closer to your stem goals
to start looking at the world of science
from a different perspective go to
brilliant.org slash nutshell and sign up
for free
and there's an extra perk for
kurtzgazzak viewers the first 200 people
to use the link get 20 percent off their
annual membership which unlocks all of
brilliant's courses in maths science and
computer science at courts and we love
to create things that seem impossible at
first
brilliant can help you acquire the
skills to do that
[Music]
wait
[Music]
you